so this is fruit roll-up and butter the
fruit roll-up and the butter is frozen i
had in the freezer overnight i always do
this this is vinegar and time that's a
whole stick of butter oh yeah
so dip it dip it dip here and
when she dipped it in vinegar
and the fruit roll up around it my
question is
who would even come up with that like
who would think like oh let me just wrap
a stick of butter and a fruit roll up
and dip it in vinegar it's her thing she
like only does butter like videos she
just eats frozen sticks of butter
frozen yeah
dip it dip it dip it
[Music]
that just makes me uncomfortable she
likes it too and she like eating the
whole thing yeah you don't want that no
would you want that would you i would
try it
i'm sensing a lot of judgment
there's a lot of judgment yeah
you're yucking my young
why do you guys keep trying to take my
phone away
anyways my food looks a little
unseasoned let me season it real quick
[Music]
a bite and you saw those feet they saw
those feet the dirt
it was black
i saw i saw a crust falling off i saw it
i don't think i'll ever look at that the
same again like every time
i see chicken i'm not getting chicken
for a while now thank you
would you do this
[Music]
too much cheese
no wait wait
500k congrats yeah but wait what if
you're like those intolerant this meal
is not for you thank you dude
it's just like unhealthy for
i guess our entertainment but like it's
really gross would you eat that though
like i try it
i would try to i don't like when people
do foods like just for the aesthetic
like grossness of it you should want to
eat that like
it's such a waste of
cheese you can make like 100 grilled
cheeses
i don't even know why i'm trying this
i like oreos
i do do you like mustard no not already
mustard gross like in and of itself
i didn't know
[Music]
she doesn't seem to want to eat this
either so why is she doing it i feel
like i'm desperate because
so her thing is people tell her things
to eat in her comments and she just
wants me to start telling me how much
and she loves mustard
that's like kind of a lot of mustard for
an oreo i know
let's just wait
[Music]
oh she ate it weird too
i mean i would
i can't tell if she likes it or not i
think she does she likes it oh she's
putting more she's putting more
no that's nasty no now that's nasty like
now you have to try no no but like
it's not actually good
you haven't tried it you can't knock it
down i've tried it i've tried mustard
and i've tried oreos yeah but it might
cancel it like
it's like a sweet and like savory sort
of thing i just don't trust her
i think she's lying to me and that's how
i feel mustard and cannoli dip though
let me put you on
no no oreos dip oreos and cannoli
mustard yes cannoli dipping mustard no
[Music]
all right
okay let's go over here
mustard and oreos i might be regretting
this
[Music]
no no instant now this is out and you
know oh i wanna
have another
[Music]